the mechanics of this character are
massive everything about this project is
a question mark this year the mechanical
geniuses of legacy effects have to
mechanize two characters not just giant
creature but small alien his cockpit guy
there are really two major facets to the
mechanical build for this character
there's the heavy stuff the mechanical
skeleton that needs to support
everything and most of that is going to
be man powered the other facet of
mechanics is the animatronics the
animatronics are the servo actuated
mechanical functions that bring a lot of
character to the creature eye movement
nostril flare jaw open and shut and the
moves of the fingers so Alan Scott has
divvied up the jobs between a few guys
first it please welcome jock we split
the jaw to get the front of the Johnny
fast by doing this sub jaws it's a
little cheat remove just the tip of the
jaw when he's speaking cuz he needs to
speak
after that sculpt those below let us
know asides eyeballed or their sculpting
around so then we could start making eye
mechanisms they always give the heads to
con is he's so good at it but I want to
build one if I can I'd love to build
that little alien at the top
he's gonna have head up down side to
side jaw upper lower lip to get kind of
like sockpuppet talking
Jim said that it was my Sistine Chapel
and that I'm taking forever but I feel
like I went pretty fast
how do we power the hand it's like we
don't know that that's gonna work yet
but we did a test for a finger and we
realized that's not gonna work so we got
to redesign the finger redesign a
mechanism see if we can even do it so
there's zero margin for error
it all works theoretically in the
computer but to make it the most
efficient possible so I'm gonna make all
the parts all at once
and then it's all gonna come together
real fast at the end we have these super
lightweight shells and we put these
servos in the joints here and these
servos even though they look small they
have 475 once's of torque which is more
than enough and they're very very fast
in my history of hand making this is
definitely the largest hand I've ever
made time is the one thing you cannot
buy and that's the one thing I wish I
always whether it's this or a movie or
commercial I always wish I had more time
in this shop doing the heavy welding and
working on the heavy mechanical
structure we have Peter Weir Clark Jim
kindig and Brian the Manning I've never
done anything this big that is manually
operated before anything like this I've
done is hydraulics or pneumatics you
know really the hardest part is figuring
out how to get this huge thing to move
in a way that is not gonna kill the
puppeteers as well as having the
character have fluidity and have kind of
living movement as opposed to looking
like there's somebody inside
you know bench-pressing it it's all
about weight distribution and everything
so it's how much steel stuff we have to
put in there to make it safe so it
wasn't a doubt that we couldn't do it is
just how much how big the neck mech is a
couple different parallelograms that are
sort of working in concert to give the
head a kind of a smooth and relatively
lifelike movement with while still being
able to have kind of good leverage for
the puppeteer in terms of the moving
what's going to be a huge head around
I've done a billion projects and you
always say to yourself I don't know how
we're gonna get this done we're never
gonna get this done and somehow on the
last day it's all sitting there and it
all works and you just can't believe it
that's just everybody working together
task of building that head
my name is Monday
pretty much done by Friday yeah
when a character starts to move that's
when the magic happens that's when you
get people rubbing their eyes and
pinching themselves it's the movement
and that's where the mechanics are
responsible for it was surreal because
everything almost moved in slow motion
you just get to look around the crowd
and it smiles and people taking pictures
and commenting and and it was a it was
um you know which Stan was there I mean
it was it was remarkable
check out the wired channel the scene
calm for the entire giant creatures
series